if you want to get more leads or you
want to grow your business you got to
let more people know about your stuff
and there's only two ways to do that you
let people know one-on-one or you let
people know one to many you can have
private communication and you have
Public Communication so private being
think about a DM think about a text
think about phone call think about an
email versus a bulletin board a post a
story where this gets confusing for
people is that they hear the things
called inbound and outbound people don't
even know what they mean the definition
of inbound as I Define it is that the
first contact with a customer is done
publicly the definition of outbound is
that the first Contact of the customer
is done privately even if someone comes
in through an ad that was public and
then eventually gets to a phone call it
was an inbound lead because they saw
your stuff publicly and then they came
towards you if the first time they saw
me was from a text or an email or a call
then that is an outbound lead simply
understanding the language you use to
advertise to get people to know about
our stuff informs how we advertise to
them